[Music]
iw in Kruiswijk he correct messages in
bottles of the beach
in thor the voor here's a project talking
about twelve hundred messages contents
mijn vol de time in the world and
instead er drew i know that there are already people
he walks the cloud on the beach  and sea
dare prices
[Music]
no my 10th that three iphone 3 of dam
gyro the third was surprised to find is
with seats and that adesso bryce was the cover
slat and so fast foil of dam and
that's why the side it ok poor
collecte of messages in bottles
and find my message symbol bos aan de
beach of zandvoort were lief en dan de
die lens messages and bottles is slow
mail in take you
days weeks or month to find a bottle
and i don' t van on the beach opened  he
points with it but your backache and at home
eyeopen the
admit second surprise
this is the door my go to first letter
syrup ianden twenty-eight of august in
my kinetic 3rd prize myth of lucy
violetta
[Music]
broad thing is something you can think
a  bout what you liking are you talking
with somebody your interrupted and
chain and so before you expect it
are you driving chanting you can right on
your own nobody's interrupting you
and are you can the people
i know the internet then
have my own beer out in  oil of
few times wit sam buddy icon to log in
and with my glasses influence this collection
and he sees the methods and remember how
much fun who it for the wajong
[Music]